este es otro problema que me envió
cortazzo me gustan mucho estos problemas
pues a primera vista parecen simples y
de hecho las soluciones son bastante
simples pero la aparente falta de
información que proporcionan hace que
sea difícil inclusive empezar a abordar
estos problemas te voy a ser honesto con
este problema en un principio me atoré
hasta que me di cuenta que es lo que
piden y cómo encontrarlo así que en este
problema tenemos a ver que toma el tren
a casa a las 4 llegando a la estación a
las 6 todos los días
manejando la misma velocidad su esposo
la recoge en la estación un día ella
toma el tren una hora antes y llega a
las 5 su esposo sale de casa para
recogerla a la misma hora usual
a la misma hora usual sería entonces su
esposo sale de casa para recogerla a la
hora usual aquí hay algo por considerar
a qué hora sale usualmente el esposo
veamos cómo está la cosa esto lo que
normalmente ocurre lo voy a hacer en
verde
normalmente ella llega a las 6
aquí lo tenemos llega a la estación a
las 6 yo no sé si esto que sale a las 4
nos sirve de algo y el marido llega a la
estación justo cuando ella está llegando
así que para encontrarle a la estación
él tiene que viajar
no sé bueno déjame ponerlo de esta
manera porque así es como lo estoy
visualizando así es como lo estoy
pensando
así es que ahí llega a él a las 6 de la
tarde también llega él y aquí ahora
salió cuánto tiempo le tomo digamos
entonces que le toma de minutos llegará
y le toma un tiempo te que desconocemos
si llega a las 6 quiere decir que salió
a las 6 menos te si te es 30 minutos
salió a las 5 y media si te es una hora
salió a las 5
así es que sale
sale a las 6
- de cualesquiera que sean las unidades
de tema la recoge y que hace la lleva de
regreso a casa correcto así que regresa
a casa déjame hacerlo con una línea más
delgada se regresa a casa suponemos que
no se pierde el tiempo cuando le está
recogiendo en la estación ella
simplemente sube al coche el auto gira y
emprenden el viaje de regreso así es que
regresan y esto les lleva el mismo
tiempo de correcto entonces a qué horas
llegan de regreso si salió te minutos
antes de las seis llegó a la estación y
regreso después de los mismos de minutos
entonces llega llega llega a las seis
más t y cuánto tiempo empleo en la ida y
la vuelta bueno si salió a las seis
menos t y regreso a las seis más te hace
la diferencia 6 más te menos seis menos
de los seis se cancelan t menos menos 32
te le tomo 2 t minutos esto es obvio si
le tomó t minutos de ida y t minutos de
regreso en total le tomó 12 minutos
hasta ahí vamos bien ahora qué pasa en
este día en particular dice que el
esposo sale de casa para recogerla a la
hora usual de nueva cuenta él sale él
sale voy a hacer esto en rojo él sale él
sale a las 6 menos
correcto y entonces como ella llega
temprano le va a tomar menos tiempo pues
la va a encontrar en el camino y eso no
lo vamos a etiquetar por el momento solo
vamos a mostrar la gráfica ese día él
viaja un tiempo menor pues ese día en
particular ella llegó antes y tuvo que
caminar eso es lo que nos están diciendo
aquí que ya llegó antes a la estación
llegó a las cinco por lo cual empezó a
caminar y se encontraba en el camino así
es que la distancia que recorrió fue
menor y por tanto el tiempo empleado
también fue menor y entonces cualquiera
que haya sido ese tiempo es el mismo que
le toma de regreso así es que para el
viaje de regreso le va a tomar el mismo
tiempo exactamente el mismo tiempo y que
nos dicen se encuentran en el camino y
llegan a casa 20 minutos antes de lo
usual
tenemos que normalmente llegan a las 6
más t
eso es lo usual pero ahora van a llegar
20 minutos más temprano así es que van a
llegar a las 6
más té que es lo usual -20 van a llegar
20 minutos antes entonces cuál es el
tiempo total de viaje del marido ese día
cuánto tiempo viajó ese día
básicamente él viajó 20 minutos menos
del tiempo usual sale al mismo tiempo y
llega a 20 minutos antes si hacemos la
resta de 6 más de menos 20 menos 6 menos
te vamos a obtener 2 t menos 20 y eso es
casi obvio quizás no tendría que haber
dibujado esto podrías haber considerado
que existe es el tiempo que normalmente
le toma en ir a la estación en un día
normal le va a tomar de ida y de vuelta
dos minutos el día de hoy sale a la
misma hora llega 20 minutos antes por lo
cual le tomo 2 t menos 20 y esto como
nos sirve bueno con esto podemos
calcular cuánto le toma en ir a recoger
a su esposa si el tiempo que le toma en
if y regresar es 2 t menos 20 el tiempo
para ir a recoger sería la mitad de esto
es decir t menos 10 para
y te 10 para regresar así es que en esta
ocasión le tomó 10 minutos menos para
recogerla así es que aquí las la recogió
aquí tenemos la clave normalmente cuando
le toma de minutos él llega a las 6 en
esta ocasión y empezó a caminar porque
llegó más temprano y él llega a 10
minutos antes el marido la encuentra 10
minutos antes de lo que normalmente lo
hace de acuerdo te menos 10 normalmente
llega a las 6 o llega 10 minutos antes
así es que se encuentran a las 550 betis
su marido se encuentran a las 5 50 y la
pregunta es
cuántos minutos camino ver cuántos
minutos camino pero recuerda llegó una
hora antes y llegó a las cinco que fue
cuando empezó a caminar ella llega a las
cinco y empieza a caminar y se
encuentran a las 5 50
así es que ella caminó 50 minutos este
es un problema muy interesante porque de
alguna manera es un problema fácil pero
por otro lado te dan información que no
sirve de nada lo más evidente es este
dato de las 4 que no nos sirve
absolutamente de nada es información
innecesaria pero lo demás queda muy
abstracto no nos dan detalles pudimos
calcular cuánto tiempo camina sin
necesidad de saber la velocidad a la que
ella camina o la velocidad a la que
maneja el esposo o la distancia dónde se
encuentran o la distancia de la estación
a la casa sin necesidad de eso pudimos
calcular cuánto tiempo camina en fin
interesantísimo problema gracias de
nuevo a cortas yo